today we're talking about io 2022
summits role certifications and a shift
in shopping habits that might surprise
you
i'm jenny brown and welcome to this week
in cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
google i o is back may 11th through 12th
and all content is virtual and free for
everyone connect with developers from
around the world for thoughtful
discussions learn from google experts
and get a first look at our latest
developer products
this year the program looks a little bit
different you can catch all keynotes
product announcements and learning lab
content on day one and then come back
for day two when all technical sessions
will be available on demand
register and check out the program at
io.google
our 2022 google cloud summit series is
in full swing and you can be among the
first to learn about new solutions
across data machine learning
collaboration security sustainability
and more
we've got several events in the upcoming
weeks where you'll hear from experts
explore customer perspectives engage
with interactive demos and gain valuable
insights to help you accelerate your
business transformation
be sure to bookmark the google cloud
summit series website to easily find
updates as news develops
we've rebranded the professional
collaboration engineer certification to
the professional google workspace
administrator certification and we've
updated the relevant learning path
check out the blog for more details and
an interview about the google workspace
administrator role and how demand and
preparation for this skill set has
changed over the years
shifting work habits more online
shopping options rising inflation and
stretch supply chains are just a few of
the factors making it harder to discern
what's top of mind for shoppers today
and while price unsurprisingly continues
to be a major consideration in purchases
the average shopper is increasingly
paying close attention to the values of
consumer goods brands and how
eco-friendly their products and
practices are
head to the blog to learn more from this
research and how brands can adapt
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us and we'll see
it in the cloud
you